like I played with trains when I was a
kid
this 89 year old has been obsessed with
trains all his life
I had electric train up in the attic of
my house so what's a train loving
retired engineer to do build a giant
train set in his Mendocino California
vineyard of course
my name is Mac slinger and this is the
vector system
[Music]
[Applause]
the fact or isn't just a big toy it's a
working concept that depends on magnets
and is pulled along by pressure in the
vacuum to sound like Elon Musk's
Hyperloop concept forget it
the inspiration for this model train is
a modern spin on a very old railroad
idea like Victorian England old in the
early days of the railroad engineers
like a sambar Kingdom Brunel thought
they had a better idea than slapping a
loud heavy locomotive on every train
they called it the atmospheric railway
but it never really worked out as well
as they hoped the first idea was very
very similar to what they did in the
1800s had they had the magnets that we
have today the high-strength magnets
probably would have done the same thing
we're doing now here's how it works the
two parts of the train are the interior
part the inside the power to this would
be the power tube an exterior we have a
thrust carriage and we have a passenger
car the thrust carriage is coupled to
the passenger car by us on permanent
magnets
the thrust carriage is inserted within
the thrust - and so as the thrust
carriage rules so does the passenger
carriage it's possible to move the
passenger carriage down the track simply
by applying pressure behind or vacuum in
front of the thrust carriage like this
of course it takes more than a huff and
a puff to get a full sized version down
the track this one uses powerful vacuum
pumps they're electric which means the
Train could be powered by renewable
energy using vacuum power instead of an
engine keeps the train light enough to
tackle hails no normal train could ever
ascend well the advantage of the system
like this is that we can not only climb
steep grades we can we could climb
grades in excess of ten ten percent
grades but we can also go down those
grades and we can use what we call
atmospheric braking so a lot of times it
just is important that you do nominate
up the grade in a safe mode so if it's
such a great idea why are there Vektor
systems
whooshing all over the place well I
think everyone else is sort of tied in
to the standard gauge railroad trains
that we have today even our high speed
trains of today are standard and I think
that's sort of a stagnation point in the
way people think spoken like a true
disruptor slinger is approaching his
tenth decade but has no intention of
slowing down I want to keep working
until I
I have my driver's license hello I'm 93
I'd like to be around and then go for it
the next time too
but bringing Vektor to life will take a
serious pile of cash and years of
political wrangling at a minimum slinger
knows this but he sees the world through
the eyes of an engineer and holds faith
that the better solution will win out
I think we'll make it happen maybe maybe
not in my lifetime but we'll make it
happen
you